December,
yeah.
In the city of Bastogne,
Belgium during the battle of the bulge,
the American soldiers primarily from
the hundred and first airborne division,
but also from the nine 69th artillery
battalion and Combat Command B of the 10th
Armored Division.
We're surrounded by Germans.
They were outnumbered by
approximately five to one.
They were lacking in cold weather gear.
They were short on ammunition and
low on food and medical supplies.
The weather was horrible
due to heavy cloud cover.
Resupply from the air was not possible.
They appeared to be doomed.
That is certainly what
the Germans thought.
So on the 22nd of December,
the German sent a message with two young
German officers offering an opportunity
for the Americans to surrender
the message.
Read
to the u s a commander of the
encircled town of Bastogne.
The fortune of war is changing
this time.
The USA forces in [inaudible]
near Bastogne have been
encircled by strong German
armored units.
Yeah.
More German armored units have crossed
the river or Fu near or Fruitville have
taken marsh.
I have reached st who bear by
passing through on Bray Cbrei Tla.
Libra mall is in German hands.
There was only one possibility
to save the Incircl,
the USA troops from total annihilation.
That is honorable surrender
of the encircled town.
Yeah.
In order to think it
over a term of two hours,
we'll be granted beginning with
the presentation of this note.
If this proposal should be rejected,
one German artillery core and six heavy
a battalion's are ready to annihilate
the USA troops in and near Bastogne.
The order for firing will be given
immediately after this two hours term.
All the serious civilian losses caused
by this artillery fire would not
correspond with the well
known American humanity
signed the German commander,
the American commander
General Anthony Mcauliffe.
Upon hearing this offer
didn't like the idea at all.
In fact,
his initial response was simply nuts.
After a little discussion with his staff
on what the proper written response
would be,
they decided that was the proper response.
So they put together a formal note
on letterhead to return to the German
commander.
It red
22 December,
1944 to the German commander nuts
signed the American
commander on Christmas Eve.
General Mcauliffe sent out a message
to his troops in the besieged city.
It red
headquarters hundred and first Airborne
Division Office of the Division
Commander 24 December, 1944
what's Mary about all this you ask,
we're fighting.
It's cold. We aren't home. All true,
but what has the Proud Eagle Division
accomplished with its worthy comrades of
the 10th Armored Division, the
705th tank, destroyer battalion,
and all the rest? Just
this. We have stopped cold.
Everything that has been thrown
at us from the north, east, south,
and West.
We have identifications from four German
Panzer divisions to German infantry
divisions and one German
parachute division.
These units spearheading the
last desperate German lunge.
We're headed straight west for key points.
When the Eagle Division was heard,
the ordered to stem the advance,
how effectively this was done
will be written in history,
not alone in our divisions, glorious
history, but in world history.
Okay.
The Germans actually did surround us.
Their radios blared our doom.
Their commander demanded our surrender
in the following in Putin arrogance
and that's when the general added in the
note of the German surrender demand and
he gave his response,
the simple response of nuts,
do you want it all the troops to know?
And then he closed out the memo explaining
their current situation on the ground.
The message continued.
Allied troops are counter
attacking in force.
We continued to hold
Bastogne by holding Bastogne.
We assure the success
of the allied armies.
We know that our division commander
General Taylor will say, well done.
We are giving our country
and our loved ones at home,
a worthy Christmas present
at being privileged to take
part in this gallon feet
of arms are truly making for ourselves.
Well,
merry Christmas.
A C McAuliffe.
Well,
the Germans did attack Bastogne on
Christmas Day and they did initially break
through the American perimeter,
but the American soldiers stood
their ground and defeated the attack,
eventually destroying
all the German tanks.
Then the next day, the 26th
of December, General Patents,
Fourth Armored Division along
with the 26th infantry division,
broke through to Bastogne and opened up
a quarter to relieve the embattled but
Victoria's troops.
It was a glorious example of will and
defiance and undaunted courage in the face
of seemingly insurmountable odds.
And it was an example
of the victory of light
over darkness.
But let us never forget
that forever you victory.
There is a cost.
There is sacrifice.
And one letter home
also written on Christmas Eve,
December 24th,
1944 from the battle of the bulge
by Lieutenant Colonel Arthur Blair,
the commanding officer.
Yeah.
Of the 268 field artillery battalion who
was born in New Orleans and raised in
Mississippi.
This letter shows some of that sacrifice.
The letter was written to
Colonel Blair's parents,
but in the letter he also speaks of his
young wife Mary and their three year old
daughter Susan.
This is what he wrote.
Do Your folks
well,
so this is Christmas Eve.
I've spent a lot of lonely ones. Those
when I've been away from you and Mary.
Yeah,
but I've never spent
one quite this lonely.
Yeah,
and one in which the Christmas spirit
seems so lacking in the surroundings.
Even the first one,
if the war with Mary leaving the
next day was not so bad as this one,
then I had things to worry
about and lots of work to do,
but here everything is as it has been
the same day in day out routine and all
I have to think of is how much I miss
you and Mary and Suzy and what
fund and how comfortable and right
it would be
if we were all spending Christmas
Eve and Christmas together.
We will have Turkey tomorrow.
Yeah.
Then some of the men will have received
Christmas packages and that will be the
extent of our Christmas.
There is no peace around us,
no peace in our hearts.
The Christmas star is an airplane flair.
The three wise men,
where are they now?
There's nothing here,
but anger and men's hearts.
The wisest men are those who do the best
job of killing the enemy while avoiding
death themselves.
The mangers are corrupt with dead and
rotting cattle and the village ends gape
at the night through the glass list,
windows and tireless roofs.
The gifts of the Maggi
are steel and flame
and high explosives,
but deep in my heart,
yeah,
I know that peace will come again
and families will again be together
for God and his son are watching over
us and protecting us all as well as we
will let them.
So
in the hope of tomorrow
then the piece to dear
dad and mom,
merry Christmas to you
and a happy and peaceful new year.
All my love.
Your son
Arthur.
Well,
Arthur did not make it home
to be with his family again
the next day,
Christmas 1944 as he was
wishing the officers and men
of his battalion and Merry
Christmas, a German shell hit
wounding several of the men
and killing Colonel Arthur W.
Blair.
He was one of the 19,000 Americans
killed in the battle of the bulge.
Then one of the thousands
upon thousands upon thousands
that have died for our flag
and the ideals of freedom
that it represents.
Carnal. Blair's executive officer
wrote a letter to the family
and said,
the memory of the kernel is one that will
always be kept green by those who knew
him,
had served with him.
He was an outstandingly gallon officer,
a fine leader,
and above all else,
a true gentleman
on the field of battle
where there can be no sham.
He proved it beyond the
question of a doubt.
Okay?
And the executive officer signed
off the letter quoting Shakespeare
when her ratio bid,
a final farewell to his friend Hamlet.
Now cracks and noble heart.
Good night,
sweet prince and flights of
angels sing the to thy rest,
to all those noble souls
that left us too young.
Third cracked our hearts.
We bid you the same goodbye.
May flights of angels
send you to your arrest.
We will remember you always,
and we are thinking of you
this holiday season.
Merry Christmas.
Have a happy new year to all
and may there be peace on earth.